quand j'ai vu passer l'appel à
candidatures
avec ce titre imparfaite j'ai
immédiatement pensé que c'était pour moi
en effet qu'est-ce qui caractérise le
mieux ma vie et en particulier la
parentalité que cet adjectif
mais devenir un parent un parfait c'est
difficile si si je vous assure pour ma
part j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à
arriver moi au départ j'étais un parent
nul
enfin c'est ce que je sentais alors ça
c'était très facile
il me suffisait de mettre à l'écouté de
ma petite voix intérieure celle qui
depuis toujours critique on remet en
cause tout ce que je fais exemples assez
récents
tu vas quand même pas postuler pour un
félix tu es incapable de parler devant
un public
en plus des thés nul au théâtre ça va
être une catastrophe voilà donc
j'imagine que certains d'entre vous
connaissent ce genre de petites voix
donc j'étais un parent qui se sentaient
nul surtout à l'arrivée de mon deuxième
d'ailleurs parce que avec la naissance
de mon aîné ma fille je vais pas devenir
mère m'avait fait gagner de la confiance
en moi changer de statut ça n'allait pas
trop mal par contre dès la grossesse de
mon second bay la petite voix est revenu
plus puissante que jamais ma fille avait
deux ans elle était très en colère
et moi j'étais fatigué et puis même si
c'est pas une excuse pendant cette
grossesse j'ai eu la dengue et c'est là
que m'est arrivé ce que je m'étais juré
de ne jamais faire j'ai levé la main sur
mon enfant je n'oublierai jamais son
regard ce jour là ses yeux remplis de
larmes et d'incompréhension qui se sont
levés vers moi et je me suis hays
tellement fort surtout quand j'ai vu la
trace de de mes doigts sur sa toute
petite cuisse j'étais instit
j'avais eu des classes de 30 élèves en
maternelle en banlieues dites difficiles
et pourtant malgré tout l'émerveillement
que j'avais pu ressentir parfois je
n'avais jamais tapé aucun de mes élèves
donc la voilà la petite voix est revenu
plus plus puissante que jamais je
m'étais promis à moi même de ne jamais
taper mes enfants il avait failli donc
je me sentais nul incapable incompétente
et puis je traînais matt stone de
culpabilité et je n'avançais plus mais
je savais pas trop à qui me confier mon
fils aîné j'étais à la fois heureuse et
puis complètement perdu j'avais une
maison dans un état indescriptible
incapable de m'en occuper et je me
sentais aussi incapable de m'occuper de
mes enfants comme j'aurais aimé vraiment
le faire une mer un peu en burn-out
probablement mon rêve d'avoir quatre
enfants s'était évaporé et puis ces lacs
internet a changé ma vie s'est découvert
une liste de discussion qui s'appelait
parents conscients elle s'appelle
toujours d'ailleurs
elle a été créée en 2001 par catherine
dumonteil kremer et à et aidé des
milliers de parents à survivre donc je
situe le décor on est en août 2003 j'ai
deux enfants je ne m'en sors pas leur
papa est au travail dans la journée et
je vis sur une petite île au milieu du
pacifique
et donc je m'inscris sur cette liste de
discussion mon premier message est très
clair il s'intitule au secours et je
parle de mon petit qui marche à quatre
pattes et de ma fille qu'il pousse et du
bruit que fait la tête quand elle vient
cogner sur le carrelage est dans une des
premières réponses que je reçois sur
cette liste il ya cette phrase oh oui le
bruit de la tête sur le carrelage c'est
vraiment horrible
et puis pas bon non donc en fait je
comprend très vite que dans ce groupe
personne ne va m'apporter de solution
miracle mais ce que je sens aussi c'est
que j y être comprise et acceptée sans
jugement par des parents qui traversent
ou qui ont traversé les mêmes
difficultés que moi et je sens très vite
que c'est précieux
ce dont je n'ai pas encore conscience
c'est à quel point ça va changer ma vie
à quel point de fil en aiguille de
réflexion on travaille sur moi je vais
donc devenir une mère imparfaite donc
par contre j'aurais bien sûr préciser
que le titre de cette liste par en
conscience pas dire il ya les parents
conscients d'un côté les parents
inconscients de l'autre même si quand
nos enfants étaient petits et qu'on nous
disait
oulala mes quatre enfants qu'est ce que
vous êtes courageux je répondais souvent
en souriant que je pense qu'on était
surtout inconscient mais là pour cette
liste ça va plutôt dire que c'est
important de prendre conscience de tous
les mécanismes qui peuvent être à
l'oeuvre de la parentalité
une des premières prises de conscience c
contient assez rarement les rênes en
fait parce que entre les mécanismes
inconscients les automatismes acquis le
fait qu'on fonctionne souvent soit en
reproduction sont en opposition totale à
la reproduction
voilà on n'est pas vraiment aux
commandes et cette prise de conscience
elle est assez importante parce qu'elle
nous permet de nous poser la question
est ce qu'on est vraiment le parent
qu'on a envie d'être ou celui que nos
proches ou la société nous impose
c'est aussi sur cette liste que j'ai
découvert les passionnants travaux
d'alice miller sur les conséquences à
l'âge adulte
toutes les violences subis dans
l'enfance il est aussi découvert les
coudes des émotions les miennes celles
de mes enfants
un mode de vie qui a considérablement
amélioré nos relations
et puis j'ai aussi compris que c'était
nos imperfections qui faisait de chacun
d'entre nous des parents uniques et
c'était à nous de créer ensuite la vie
de famille qui allait avec et qu'on
pouvait accompagner nos enfants dans
l'amour et la confiance malgré tout mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que jamais personne
ne m'a vendu de recettes en me
promettant un bonheur éternel la
parentalité à l'époque on l'appelait
alternative on dit souvent plutôt poser
maintenant plutôt positive nous nous
vend pas de trucs clé en main où tout va
se résoudre mais elle va plutôt nous
appeler à nous atteler à la tâche pour
créer en fait notre propre parentalité
je me souviens de la première rencontre
dans la vie réelle avec certains des
membres de la liste discussions et du
stress qui avait précédé ce que
j'aimerais vraiment peur de pas me
sentir à ma place et puis quand la
rencontre a eu lieu il y avait des
parents en tous genres des parents avec
tous les looks tous les métiers tous les
milieux et ça m'avait vraiment rassuré
parce qu'en fait je m'étais 10 mai
en fait c'est pour tout le monde quoi
c'était vraiment chouette
l'étape suivante ça a été de me dire
d'accepter de pouvoir confier mes
difficultés et pour ça souvent le plus
difficile c'est de trouver la bonne
personne
parce qu'évidemment canton à l'autre le
courage d'avouer qu'on n'en peut plus si
c'est pour s'entendre dire j'étais sûre
kate était incapable d'être équipé de
quatre enfants ou bien encore jean
médecin que je comprends pas ton
problème
bon alors évidemment ça sert à rien de
ce côté là je dois dire que j'ai eu
vraiment de la chance parce que entre
les amis que je m'étais faite sur la
liste de discussion
et puis d'autres amis que j'ai
rencontrés dans des réunions d'une
association de maternage proche de chez
moi j'avais déménagé ou un homme mon
fils je vais quitter le pacifique
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression d'avoir
beaucoup d' écoute et puis surtout la
sensation que je n'étais pas seul
une de mes astuces favorite quand je
sentais que vraiment tout devenait trop
difficile
c'était d'inviter une amie à la maison
avec des enfants ou même d'ailleurs que
des enfants à ce sujet ma voisine était
enceinte de son deuxième enfant
exactement aux mêmes dates que moi le
mans 4e et quand j'invite est sa petite
à venir jouer avec mes enfants je crois
que mon ami était un peu gêné de
m'imposer un enfant de plus et
maintenant elle a trois enfants sa
dernière va avoir dix ans et je crois
qu'elle a bien pris conscience que quand
sa fille venait jouer chez moi mes
enfants étaient aux petits soins pour
elle ils se chamaillaient pas et
vraiment il m'offrait de très précieuses
minutes de calme et de tranquillité
donc quand je recevais une amie je
l'avais très très vite mis de côté
l'idée de recevoir dans une maison ne
serait-ce que présentable
parce que vraiment mon besoin à ce
moment là mais c'était d'avoir un temps
pour nous que les enfants jouent pendant
qu'on pouvait boire un thé papauté se
confier rires et puis ensuite on veut
d'un petit jeu de société tous ensemble
voilà on a passé un bon moment
tant pis pour la
pour la poussière sur les bibelots
j'aimais bien l'astuce que quelqu'un
avait donné sur la liste de discussion
qui était de laisser l'aspirateur tout
le temps au milieu de la pièce de vie
comme ça si quelqu'un arriver à
l'improviste on pouvait toujours lui
dire j'allais justement passer
l'aspirateur
alors évidemment c'est une technique qui
ne dupe personne si le sol est jonché de
jouer les pythies ya trois jours de
vaisselle qui trône dans l'évier
ça c'est sûr il n'y a pas très longtemps
je lisais un article ou des mamans
raleigh se plaignait sur des soi-disant
adeptes de la parentalité positive dont
les photos instagram ressembler à des
images de conte de fées alors je
voudrais vous lire la définition de la
parentalité positive du magazine peuple
c'est un magazine associatif parental
auquel je collabore depuis sa création
en octobre 2012
mais vous allez voir qu'on est assez
loin du conte de fées ménagers en fait
donc c'est parentalité centré sur la
joie de vivre le plaisir d'être ensemble
les besoins de chacun le soutien sur le
chemin de soi cette forme de parentalité
demande de la vigilance
un travail de prise de conscience de nos
blessures d'enfants pour éviter ainsi
toute violence physique et psychologique
même considérée comme légère donc c'est
une définition qui n'impose pas une
obligation de résultat mais qui offre
une proposition de moyens et mélanger
avec un parent un parfait en gros ça
donne un parent qui fait ce qu'il peut
en sachant qu à l'instant t c'est son
maximum mais qui du coup ne va pas
hésiter s'excuser quand il n'a pas été à
la hauteur
et puis surtout bien sûr d'aller à aller
demander de l'aide quand les mêmes
problèmes se présentent encore et
toujours
[Musique]
je savais que ça allait arriver
le petit moment où c'est un peu flou
[Musique]
donc on était la définition du parent
donc le parent c'est aussi un parent qui
va être à l'écouté de son enfant mais il
va pas demander à son enfant de l'écouté
ou dead son pote
et puis je ne sais plus je le savais oui
bien sûr que je voulais ajouter
évidemment mais ça va presque sans le
dire c'est que les enfants n'ont
absolument pas besoin de parent parfait
bien sûr ils ont besoin de parents
humain donc pour en revenir aux images
des photos fallait faut des photos
instagram dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est un peu l'impression que ces
personnes n'ont pas complètement compris
le concept si elle imagine que l'idée
c'est de se montrer sans faiblesse et
sans bazar dans une sorte de perfection
pour moi c'est un petit côté poudre aux
yeux
instagram n'existait pas quand mes
enfants étaient petits
et fort heureusement parce que j'imagine
le malaise que j'aurais pu ressentir si
j'avais vu ses jolies mamans a prêté
jusqu'au bout des ongles avec des
enfants tout propre dans des maisons
bien rangée joliment décoré ses parents
faisant des repas maison équilibrée des
goûters d'anniversaire bio est parfait
fabricants les déguisements tout en
faisant plein de câlins en lisant plein
d'histoires en ayant des job passionnant
des vie sexuelle épanouie bref non mais
j'aurais vraiment pu croire que ça
reflétait la réalité de leur vie et que
six mois jeu n'atteignaient pas le
nirvana de la famille kinder avant mes
40 ans mais je serai une mère de famille
ayant et raté sa vie de famille quoi le
malaise depuis quelques années depuis
exactement je coordonne la journée de la
non-violence éducatif du 30 avril et
pendant longtemps j'ai été impressionné
par les parents qui osaient organiser
quelque chose ce jour là je me disais
que pour pouvoir faire quelque chose ils
devaient avoir vraiment régler tous
leurs problèmes familiaux et que donc
leur vie devait ressembler à de long
fleuve tranquille
et puis leur quotidien celui des pubs
j'avais absolument pas besoin d'un stade
romain pour me faire des films je
faisais ça très bien tout seul et puis
au fur et à mesure on ait rencontré dans
la vie réelle et je me suis rendu compte
qu évidemment il n'avait pas réglé tous
leurs problèmes mais pour la simple et
bonne raison que c'est juste impossible
évidemment les enfants grandissent les
défis change alors il ya des problèmes
qui disparaissent parce que par exemple
le petit enfant de trois ans un peu
collant c'est un problème qui est
rarement évoquée pour un enfant de 17
ans mais par contre évidemment on aura
de nouvelles difficultés qui vont être
mises à jour donc rencontrer ses parents
qui étaient capables d'aider d'autres
parents à changer de regard sur la
relation à l'enfant sans pour autant et
des parents parfaits ça m'a vraiment
permis de me rendre compte que moi aussi
malgré mes difficultés
mes imperfections tout mais quoique dans
l'accompagnement mes enfants je pouvais
à la fois être malgré tout une bonne
mère et puis aussi une source de soutien
pour d'autres parents parce que je pense
que faire part de ses difficultés c'est
assez essentiel dans le soutien et pour
moi le soutien c'est vraiment la pierre
angulaire angulaire de la parentalité
sans violence on ne peut pas y arriver
sans soutien c'est juste pas possible et
donc petit papier ça faisait longtemps
je ne sais plus où j'en suis
[Musique]
je voudrais ajouter évidemment qu'on n'a
pas non plus on ne demande pas non plus
à nos enfants d'être parfait puisque en
sait que c'est juste impossible pour ça
ça peut être chouette de se renseigner
sur les phases de développement de
l'enfant également de pas les brusquer
parce que des fois on voudrait qu'ils
réalisent l'impossible on voudrait qu'il
aille plus vite que la musique et
parfois même ils vont être un peu en
deçà de tout ce qu'on lit quoi donc
c'est vraiment important est alors en
faisant ça en essayant de leur apporter
un amour inconditionnel sans leur
demander de combler notre besoin
notamment un coup d'amour inconditionnel
tout en posant des limites respectueuse
quand le besoin s'en fait sentir bref ça
fait vraiment un gros boulot tout ça
c'est certain et winnicott a parlé de la
mer suffisamment bonne c'est en tout cas
comme ça que ça a été traduit en
français il doit avouer que j'aime pas
trop cette expression parce que pour moi
dans suffisant il y a des idées de ac et
penser à ces ça suffit on peut s'arrêter
alors que non évidemment on ne s'arrête
jamais les enfants grandissent les défis
change l'équilibré est toujours à
réinventer et il faut se mettre tout le
temps au travail
donc quand on a pas dead on peut
vraiment vraiment le voir comme une
source d'épuisement permanent mais avec
du soutien c'est beaucoup plus facile on
peut le considérer comme un défi
passionnant à relever au quotidien
ce qui est certain c'est qu'avec des
enfants on ne s'ennuie jamais et la
liste est vaste de tout ce qu'on peut
vivre en famille nous avons vraiment
envie d'avoir une belle relation avec
nos enfants et je crois que nous
méritons et il mérite vraiment de
chercher de l'aide quand le besoin s'en
fait sentir pour vivre cette belle
relation
un des bons moteurs parfois parfois
quand on a envie de vivre une belle
relation on a besoin de changer des
choses aussi chez nous est un assez bon
moteur pour ça c'est la culpabilité hors
pas quand on veut nous culpabiliser mais
quand on se sent soi-même coupable et
cette culpabilité elle va nous aider à
faire des choses différemment par
exemple
quand je me sentais coupable de ne pas
avoir vécu une naissance idéal pour mes
deux aînés et à chaque fois je lisais un
récit de naissance physiologique je
voyais que j'avais les larmes qui
montent et aux yeux et du coup pour mon
troisième j'ai pris les choses en main
j'ai fait des choix et nous avons vécu
une très très belle naissance
physiologique à la maison ensuite j'ai
pu lire tous les récits de naissance que
je voulais plus aucun ne m'a fait
pleurer ni culpabiliser donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est que j'ai pris les
choses en main j'ai décidé d'agir et de
ne pas rester dans mes remords et c'est
là que la culpabilité qui a un sentiment
ambivalent très intéressant fonctionne
parce qu'en fait elle vient nous
titiller là où on sent qu'on peut faire
bouger les choses donc soit pour faire
autrement
soit pour réparer mais alors attention
j'ai envie de dire des fois c'est
possible et puis des fois ce n'est pas
possible
donc c'est important aussi d'être
bienveillants envers soi même pas
seulement envers ses enfants
et ça c'est pas toujours le plus facile
je rame encore je vous avoue qu'elle
difficultés de sa portée parfois un peu
de douceur
donc j'aimerais vraiment invité les
parents qui se sentent nul s'il y en a
parmi vous à voir combien de sont pas
nulles mais seulement un parfait et
combien cette imperfection peut vraiment
les aider à aller demander de l'aide si
a besoin et pourquoi pour créer une vie
de famille dans l'amour et le respect de
chacun des membres une fille lui
familles dans lesquelles ils se sentent
vraiment bien donc le premier petit pas
ça pour être d'appeler sos parentalité
la ligne que nous tenons avec d'autres
consultants du réseau parentalité
créatif c'est un service gratuit qui est
ouvert six jours sur sept la sont les
horaires réunion et c'est vraiment 15
minutes pendant lesquelles vous pourrez
relâcher la pression pour ne pas craquer
sur vos enfants et un quart d'heure
pendant lequel vous ne serez pas jugés
et pande pour peut-être la première fois
de votre vie vous pourrez vous présenter
comme le parent que vous êtes vraiment
dans tout ça magnifique imperfections je
vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]